[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the temperature heated up in round 11 of
the candidates in Berlin as eight of the
world's elite players are in an all-out
quest to see who will challenge Magnus
Carlsen for the World Chess title
Fabiano Carwin held on to his slim lead
with a draw against Vladimir Kramnik
but surging Sergei Kuryakin defeated
Levon Aronian for his third win in five
games and is now near the top of the
standings critical matchups abound with
dreams of glory on the line
round 12 analysis of the pressure from
Holmen starts right now
[Music]
hello I'm Jennifer Sahadi welcome to
today inch as hosted at the st. Louis
chess club I am with grandmaster yasser
sarah juan happy birthday thank you so
much Jennifer delighted this year the
happiness that's right and I'm sure
everybody tuning in it was very excited
to wish you a happy one as well so
everybody reach out to us on Twitter and
at our phone line to give a little good
wishes to our birthday boy yeah sure the
love Jennifer what a tournament we're
we're witnessing here and in Berlin the
candidates it's just been fantastic and
what matchups we have today
yeah and today's round is particularly
critical but before we get into that
let's look at the standings and why do
they matter so much well Fabiano
Carolina has been on this half point
lead for a while now yasser nobody is
seeming to overtake him but today it's a
very big opportunity for mommy Dara
Sergei Kuryakin and Alex Brissac all of
whom have white and this is a really key
opportunity to try to get a win in and
catch Bobby before it might be too late
absolutely three crucial games feature
the top players and let's take a look at
those pairings to see how vital they are
well we've got Alexander Grisha playing
white against Levon Aronian that game is
underway Levon being very wounded golden
opportunity potentially for Alex
meanwhile Sergei cardiac and playing
creatively against the ever formidable
defender Fabiano catalana a lot hangs in
the balance of that game could end up
being a million-dollar chess game yasser
yeah very very wealthy and indeed at
this moment they are locked in a battle
royale and also this this matchup
between Shaq and ding that too could
very very well be a million-dollar game
as you just said that's right Mahmoud
are about playing light against England
being we run with so many opportunities
yesterday to say hey I'm in this
tournament too right it didn't work out
for him but today he could be a spoiler
for a moment I have no question about
that but we've got Maurice to go over
some deep
the key matchup today of that a rematch
between Kuryakin and Khurana absolutely
well as we remember two years ago these
two young gladiators faced off against
each other and critically Kuryakin was
able to win that big game that probably
had to win because the tie breaks were
bad for him and he went down in flames
karyakin goes on to compete against
Magnus Carlsen
and what was indeed a competitive world
championship match well now the tables
have turned
it is Fabi who is ahead a whole point as
a matter of fact Carr yakking needing to
win basically today or else Fabi will
keep an extended lead against him as you
see there Fabi has since gotten his
measure of revenge but it would be
sweeter to win today
obviously in this very big candidates
tournament
booyaka will have a thing or two to say
about that and he will most likely want
to win this game why because he's got
two big games ahead the first one
against Wesley so in that position
Wesley's been so solid lately he started
off not so great but he's been solid of
late and it would be a difficult one to
win for kuryakin and also against
England who no one has defeated in this
tournament so far he has been proven to
be extremely solid so Kuryakin will want
to take the bull by the horns and win
today and meantime Fabi he knows a draw
is okay as a matter of fact in the next
round he gets Levon Aronian who is
absolutely wounded and struggling just
to get to the finish line so that's a
big game for Fabi
he will then face off of course against
the mercurial Alex Brissac who will have
all to play for in that final round as
he is right behind Fabi a point behind
looking to get a win as well and if he
could do that then he would indeed surge
into better tiebreaks
so Fabi knows it's not secure as yet
he's gonna have to compete in this game
and they have a barn burner going on
right now Thank You Maurice and let's
take a look at LaVon struggles in this
event Levon had such a phenomenal 2017
the crank a classic Norway chess and
feed a World Cup perhaps most impressive
of all 128 player knockout that he
survived all the way to the finals and
won that's right and not only that he
also want a little tournament here in
the st. Louis is he little happen in
blitz which was you know stolen the show
by a Gary Kasparov not a retirement but
LaVon winning now that was really
awesome cuz he's such a favorite here in
st. Louis absolutely but it's been
tournament not so much right well it's
almost a tale of two halves in the first
five rounds he drew he drew he fell into
an amazing piece of preparation lost
against Vladimir Kramnik one of the best
tournaments best games of the tournament
but he bounced back with a win in round
four drew round five so after five
rounds he was at 50% looking okay but
then came just a horrible series he lost
he lost he drew he drew he lost he lost
to tumble 2-4 indeed and you know yes
I'm uh I'm getting uh so many happy
birthday wishes to our audiences for
joining us of course indeed
somebody said I usually don't this is a
good one
tomaso gimme re says happy birthday
yasser the best human on earth the best
human on earth wow wow wow wow that's a
are you thinking a lot of comments that
you can't actually say over the air on
your yes I think you're certainly in the
top 1% no I wouldn't even go there the
one percent you want a happy birthday
yeah I think we just saw the phone
number across the screen but you guys
want to call in ask a question give a
unique birthday wish to
circe Arowana three one four three six
one five four six five Colin this is
just such an important round for us
chess as we see Fabiano karana really
defending well in this form and that's
one thing I've really liked from Fabiano
he's playing against the Minister of
Defense himself look at this last move
he played or he played a few moves ago
perhaps five moves right that's some
good defense there isn't it yes
absolutely well let's just take it from
the top it came this position King from
a Russian defense that fabbi has been
employed I'm gonna say in the last few
years of his career and certainly no
surprise it will not have come as a
surprise to Sergei and the players more
or less blitz through their opening
preparations all of these moves have
been seen before and then the slightly
different take for me is this move a 2 a
3 and a lot of times white is actually
putting that playing b3 and putting his
King on b2 or simply playing King b1 a3
is a little bit of a new wrinkle h7 h6
move Knight g5 in this rather
symmetrical position can be annoying so
h7 h6 the all of these moves are again
fairly standard ik up to here rook g8 I
think a lot of people might have said
okay I'm gonna castle King's on opposite
sides let's go
however fabbi all he needs is a draw it
wasn't interested in getting into a very
big battle with Kings on opposite flanks
and we got to this position and here
again I think because of the tournament
situation
Sergei speculated with an exchange
sacrifice picked up a bishop and a pawn
for a rook the resulting position which
we're about to get to is quite deceptive
materially speaking fabbi is doing very
well
no problem however in practical terms
it's actually a very awkward position
for black to play fabbi to play this
bishop on d5 is very dominant
ship especially blacks King is a little
bit weaker than his counterpart and we
were actually sweating before we came on
the air we were worried that after move
like Queen f3 rook d7 for example the
bishop swings back to f2 and here we can
see that h4 g5 the bishop could even
come to this g3 square this would have
really put a lot of pressure on Abbey's
position instead of that move the the
attractive-looking rip d3 actually isn't
going anywhere and after this very good
counter move g7 g5
I think fabbi is basically doing quite
well at this moment g5 so much I want to
trade off the dark square bishop if I
can get the two bishops off the position
out of the position I don't think that
the company we're talking about
compensation and maybe with the with the
two bishops on the board we're talking
maybe advantage white take the two bit
take the dark square bishop off the
board and I think we're talking simple
equality I don't know I mean I see I see
what you're saying but that bishop on d5
is a monster yeah it is unassailable
pretty much I mean the only way to
undermine it is the move b5 right which
obviously is very suspect exactly you
know so if you take a look at that
situation where the bishop on d5 is
going to stay there forever
then the compensation as far as black is
concern Alliance that speaking
compensation that the plus for black is
having the exchange
however those rooks are not exactly
lined up right what they're lined up but
they're not lined up vertically yes to
penetrate into the position so they'll
never show anything so basically in this
to my eyes this is a two result position
for car yakun like why would he ever
think of losing this position I mean if
you had to bet would you say White's
gonna lose somehow how does how does
black even think about troubling right
now that said black doesn't have to win
the game but it looks like black is in
only a to result mode of
draw or loss maybe closer to the draw
maybe he's the putting up a great
defense but he's not the one thinking
about hmm let me see if I can figure
some kind of funky stuff out here I try
to win the game I mean in this position
I think it's a crazy idea but it seems
to me that some someday white might try
to engineer an H for sacrifice with g5
maybe that's a that's a little bit
extreme maybe if I'd like to maybe drop
my bishop back some out of d2 which
would be a add square and then play for
h4 and g5 and something like this it
just seems like block has nothing to do
like is waiting to figure out what White
has to do white might even play a four a
five I mean it's good arguments it seems
it just seems like I don't know what to
do for white really that that works but
right it's like white is the one who's
never gonna lose and can choose if he
keeps the battle keeps keeps it going
well I'd rather be white - what about
you guys I'd rather be white or black I
think there are three results possible I
think it's easier to play white but
again I do see three results white well
let's just take a look at something very
concrete oops
it's not black to move blacks last move
was rookie seven let's make a move for
white you mention Bishop d2 Maurice and
before we go to Bishop d2 for example
you you we like levers you know you and
I we'd say who's got the levers and you
mentioned a 485 is one there's another
one too you might it's double edge but
you might be looking at b2b for the rook
swings over to a3 and you know there's
the point there's some nasty they're
going wrong worried about some before
and then takes on d5 your c4 and your C
- oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah on a
practical level but if you look at the
concrete and here's what I want to say
just about ooh sorry Bishop d2 just
let's just see I take you take I play
Bishop e5 now really my goal is simply
to trade the dark square Bishop allowed
that to happen that's not no it's not
gonna happen you're gonna take I'm gonna
take now
f7 is obviously potential weakness and
again we should be fine very nice little
reason I totally agree with that one my
rook will drop back now you could play
like rook f3 and try to I don't know
gang up on my pawn I just wanna know
your bishops going to go because I also
have work h3 work 87 as another plan
Luke h3 work h7 and you you're going
back to e5 a definitely that creates a
little bit of a yeah okay well actually
that that's worth just taking a gander
at for just a second because here's
where I really want to go with this is
let's imagine that I play move like that
no that's why yeah and if I could just
you know get everything off the board
okay yeah now back up one move I just
played rotation yep rook h3 okay and if
you do put your Bishop on e5 I do have
Queen f5 no no yes totally legal move
and let's say get out of that pin it
might be so nasty laughing some so now
you're not as okay now if I play rock
eight seven yeah you're tying me up but
it still it feels rather temporary
ooh do I want to play rook a fake might
run into h6 oh I like rookie 3-step
rookie three f6 you have something on f6
we could sorry Queen we were going at
Queen f5 winter sighs I like yeah let me
just get in f7 okay let me just do that
one wait can I even behave on taking it
yes I'm a little skeptical but I'm not a
materialist like you pass G pawn that
goes to g8 and you're King I don't know
I haven't I haven't lined up my rooks
are not beautiful that is what that is
for sure my rooks are not beautiful
though they do look a little bit more
promising now that the dark squared
bishop sir traders that's my whole point
if you could get rid of the dark squared
Bishop a
lot of the use poison in the position
that white has because I am g5 right now
for example right may not win the game
for me but it probably is a bat probably
is a bad idea
no no no I mean I think it's a
reasonable idea again this Bishop on at
the end of the day after you wipe
everything off the board Bishop on d5 is
still a monster so I should keep Queens
and keep playing it's still white
White's the one who's playing there for
something well it does seem like to me
it seems scary for Fabiano but at the
same time you're right if he makes that
time control maybe things will flip in
the other direction
and another thing going in Carolina's
favor is he's been defending so well in
this tournament I mean remember that
game against mommy tiara where he called
me found all the best defensive moves
and even had an advantage at something
right not an advantage but there were
some lines where it looked like it was
going in his direction right no he's
been he's been very consistent and his
errors he's managed to keep at a minimum
and he's been very fortunate to I mean
again that game with Vladimir Kramnik
that could have easily Swan against him
but Kramnik Vladimir has been while
Vladimir has been stealing the show with
his games and even today fantastic game
against Wesley so we'll get to that one
to the Vladimir has been really luckily
sometimes you just need to be lucky in
the tournament to do well but over to
you Maurice what do you make yourself
you you think that this position is a
two result game at the moment well yes
sir yes you know you you are a much
better player and we just made a series
of moves and and the conclusion of that
it was still white trying to press them
that's true and what and you didn't show
you didn't prove your argument I have to
tell you that it was a great result
possibility it was always white I never
felt in danger at all
I was always white that was saying
or something yeah you would have made a
more moves to prove to me that you had
anything in there right
so I'm if you're not creating pressure
on on being right I have to feel like
it's not dangerous for white okay okay
white may not be winning right
I'm not making any claim that way right
far away from it but I just don't like
that he has to think about how to
liquidate get rid of pieces he's can't
trade off the bishops that's a strategic
goal of visit it doesn't come about in
any way he can't make it happen and even
for example you went after my H pawn I
couldn't baby tickled with h3 and just
put it on h3 so you didn't have that
possibility as well and sit there and
wonder how do you not suffer and maybe
maybe you're gonna just figure out okay
I'm gonna sit here and how do you beat
me maybe that is the right thing and
there's just a stasis on the board and
nothing else but we mentioned there are
palm breaks there before is a little bit
much but it's there it feels super
aggressive and possible and also a4 a5
is whispering in the position it does
create a little bit of risk because
white has to open his King in order to
make that happen but the route could get
to this a4 idea the rook could possibly
get to a3 and and that's full protect
actually I don't even know how you
exploit it if I play for a 45 you might
have to play a 5 yourself right
so blockade that side a or a5 I agree I
would probably have to play a 5 but that
but once you play a for you I was a
little bit more afraid of the break
before that you lost that love yes
exactly if a5 the a5 looks like it's
only Gould Enzo Indian idea yeah against
that a for it right so maybe I don't do
that but just it feels like I mean White
has five rings right right you're one
with a bishop on d5 Black has three
ranks and those were looks look silly I
just feels like another very direct idea
I'm not sure it's that good but another
very direct idea is if you fall into my
trap and you allow me the dark square
Bishop straighted you
maybe you you may play the move like
Queen f6 angling not only obviously to
take this pawn on g5 but maybe if that
Queen ever walked waltzes away
I got Queen c6 the rooks up into the H
file in that position as well creating
some damage along the H line yes I don't
know it feels it doesn't feel like it's
a it's a wit it's not a win it's far
away from it but it really feels like
White's the one with all the
possibilities to think of and if you
slip pressure this could be highly
unpleasant for you on but let me refresh
the game because I believe some moves
have been made and maybe now we can get
a better insight into the plans of the
players we did see this move Queen f3 by
the way Sergey came back to that we
thought that move was even stronger when
this work was on d1 by the way but okay
King d8 okay that's an indication right
there that fabbi doesn't have any direct
way of dealing with the pressure in he's
worried of the potential of the Queen
and Bishop on the light squares being
reversed and a queen coming to a eight
so he's played King da may be intimating
that his plan is to slip away with his
King over seven he could be it could be
jumping into the fire but Allah and
after the move King d8 we do have the
response Bishop d2 so let's just play
along for a moment with no I can't
Bishop c6 okay that answers that one
okay what else could I do to address the
pressure wait around and see what
White's plan is do some kind of a
waiting maybe rook these sixes
I do agree that my rooks feel entangled
with one another I'm not proud of these
rugs because we are in like the 26 area
these next 10 moves are not these next
14 moves are gonna have to be played at
a relatively brisk pace and that's all
these bad timing when you're the one who
has the pressure on you yeah but um
we're gonna take a quick phone call
welcome to the show let us know your
name and your question hey guys how you
doing yeah great I called yesterday
Jennifer just go upstate New York I was
gonna ask you a question I forgot
oh yeah sir you and I are a little too
remember of a Maurice and Jennifer iron
1972 World Championship and the effect
you had on us chess so I was a worldwide
phenomenon what do you think the impact
will be if we finally if Taiwan is lucky
enough on I want sinks the poor guy if
he's lucky enough to get through here to
play in the World Championship since
it's been 45 years since we've had an
American in the final so I'll just
curious yasser since you were around you
were not around back then you knew the
impact that it what do you think I'll
have now well thank you again jack for
giving us a call and asking this
question well first of all I don't think
it would have as great an impact as 1972
that was an amazing moment in time
padilha politically it was the Cold War
America versus the USSR that was just an
entire extraordinary moment in history
never to be repeated however having said
that I think it would absolutely have a
wonderful positive impact on US chess it
would be very very very nice it's a it's
a happy thought to have what could
potentially happen in case a favi were
to be the Challenger but I'd also like
to just point out that in 1995 1995
gotta Kamsky a defector from the Soviet
Union came and became a US citizen and
did play in the finals he did lose
against Anatoly Karpov in a feed a world
championship
but anyway I think it would be more
as for chess it would really help and
the publicity would be great
I totally agree as and you know to the
the caller mentioning the whole jinx
thing don't worry
yes bad luck to be superstitious tell us
about how Fabiano was gonna win all day
all day all night and all day and you
know also has the thing is the
infrastructure now it's so great with
the Seton was chess club with us chess
Federation's numbers growing with the
Pro Chesley chess calms numbers growing
right I mean I think the infrastructure
is so great right now that if we do have
a boom in publicity with something like
Fabi qualifying yeah we are ready to
scale and those people in with welcome
arms and hold onto them and don't let
them go exactly they they die well
there's no question this is a golden era
yeah age for chess and and I think you
were at the super nationals
that was a 2016 or 2017 a measure the
super Nationals were there like six
thousand competitors breaking has broken
records every time right so our
scholastics is booming chess on the
internet is great the the chess club's
itself in some ways are suffering the
success that we're having over the
internet you know because now you can
play you know 7:24 against games on
these game playing sites all over and
you know it's sort of like well your
your your club member numbers might go
down because why go to the club when you
can you know play over the internet now
having said that you know here in st.
Louis obviously the Chess Club is just
booming and we're getting members
numbers and our YouTube numbers are
going crazy version of Cobie ins video
on YouTube has hit a million downloads I
mean I mean the club is yeah the club is
really reaching its mission which is to
promote and educate and raise the
ordinance of chess in the United States
I'm very positive your comparison about
a you know
mine in life I think in the end of the
day if online becomes big enough people
want that live experience as wow dude so
even though the first glance it might
look bad I think ultimately it's good
like you know just calm even Mary its
John Bartholomew who's on internet you
know chess streaming sensation he does
he does like meetups in different cities
and and they they're packed as far as I
understand the stylistic this is being
good in the end it's a kind of way that
online dating does eventually lead to
welcome to the show
let us know your question and where
you're calling from
hello I am coming from Arizona and the
question I was going to ask you gas or
Sarah was do you know Robert Tanner I'm
one of his students I'm very aware of
the name I can't recall actually having
met him I think you did he was a TV may
be in the chess tournament the US
Championship in Denver which I'm pretty
sure you played in the u.s. junior
champion it was one in Phoenix wasn't
there a US Championship in Phoenix that
you played in yes he was like that's
right I turned the director at that's
right Arizona I think well you know how
it is with a tournament director the
less you hear from them the better the
better the organization is shout out to
Robert for all the good work he does on
chess and obviously as a pupil you seem
to be very happy with Robert so thank
you for the mention and the question and
Arizona is one of those places that does
have a booming chest scholastics right
you've got i know Robbie Adamson was in
the Chess Life magazine cover a few
years ago maybe eight years ago for like
his scholastic initiatives and is
Angelina balakov skaia lives there as
well so it's yeah Danny wrench lives
there person most of his work is on
chest out comics out but yeah he doesn't
live events as well well the chess
Emporium Scott there at the chess
Emporium he has 30 coaches 30 reaching
out to 25,000 students a year
in the greater Phoenix metropolitan area
and his work is just fantastic I mean
and Danny came through at the chess
Emporium but let's go over to Maurice
because you've got breaking news for us
over there - Maurice well we have been
paying a lot of attention to a key
matchup of course the one between
Kuryakin and Fabiano Caruana but another
extremely important matchup is taking
place between mummies Europe and England
now remember dear I was only a half a
point behind Carolina so as far as he's
concerned with two whites in the next
three games well he actually has two
whites back-to-back he figured it is
time to make a move and go after the
Chinese superstar but he didn't Lorraine
has been a very tough man to defeat in
this tournament and he really was very
unlucky not to be able to put the nail
in the coffin against Chris Chuck and in
this game this was the position you see
here a very big pawn structure for white
as far as the center is concerned but
black looking for some compensation on
the Queen side with his pawns pushing
his paws down the board and in this
position this bull shocked me the move
g4 appeared on the board looking to try
to get some attack going on this side
well he had to be careful because after
a for Bishop to c2 9 to d7 ding was
trying to trade off pieces get rid of a
pair of knights and make this side look
very porous not playing to bring the
knight back a move you liked yeah sir
Knight back to d3
he simply played Bishop to d3 and once
the Knights came off suddenly these
plans were starting to free to run down
the board Bishop to c4 Bishop back to d7
getting out of harm's way and now g5
continuing the aggressive stance on this
side h6 g5 splitting his own pawns did
white with this move Queen g5 I mean
look at this H pawn looked at the King
forever without secure shelter but going
Vauban for the wind Bishop back 27 now
this will be three a b3 III sacrificing
a pawn to get a passport on this square
the move before was played but this move
this position somebody's going to win
this is not your territory right now if
a murderer were to lose that would be
disastrous for him of course
especially if Bobby were able to
a draw in his game that's not looking
easy at all by the way and this is
shades of I think it's Kramnik and and
Carlson wasn't Cromley Carlson 20 in
2013 when both of them had to hold it
himself together in a critical last Ron
game and they both lost yes and that
caused Carlson to be able to move
forward ok it's not the last round but
the the leaders might be slipping a
little bit right now under pressure is
Fabi in his game trying to make sure he
doesn't lose my Madeira off going all in
he's of a pawn right now but that passed
pawn looks very dangerous especially
with his exposed King we see the score
right now as Kuryakin looks the jump
ding Lauren might be back in the hunt if
he wins that would be chaos again again
a single loss could change everything
we're following all the action right now
on today HS Wow Maurice that that game
between and I've got it up on my board -
between ding and Shaq that is an amazing
game the problem black is having is this
white queen that has invaded the camp of
blacks camp on e7 is reaching in the
position and basically tickling the rook
on d8 as well as a bishop on the e8
and the problem is sorry I was gonna say
the problem that black would have is he
would love to take this pawn and come
down with a check harass White's King
but he can't do it because the rook is
hanging the rook would love to take this
pawn on d4 but it can't do it because
the bishop is hanging so sorry right but
you know with the Queen on e7 normally
you would just be able to play like
rookie a as they go so it's like a
really logical configuration that we
don't see that often no we don't and so
I'm looking at a very concrete move move
I'm looking at his rook a 8 first of all
allowing now for Queen takes before but
even more serious threatening a 2 once
that Bishop capture
well the Rope will be able to capture
the bishop because it's doing so with a
check I was just trying to make heads or
tails out of King g3 but again there's a
double threat no you could take this
pawn on b4 I don't know what's going on
in this game of racism a very concrete
position well yeah okay your queen your
queen looks sophisticated on the e7 it's
all in there and stride but it's doing
nothing it's just hot it's just tying
down a bishop okay meantime if b4 falls
right this position will all be about
King safety and if we just make the
position all about King safety forget
about the past pawn in a three which
you're not going to forget about your
[Music]
but that bond is always on a3 what does
white have where do you point to white
as far okay Europe you're up a pawn sure
seems to be that you're about to lose
that point it seems to me that you
better do something now or else well
let's do something now okay let's go
defy but you follow my argument
absolutely do something now stuffs about
to happen and d5 just looks like a must
move right because you're gonna die I'm
looking at an explosive line like a two
takes on e6 holy cow whoa yes because Oh
be careful
row your rook is pinned your rule of
your rook would not mate oh you're okay
I'm a nine point eight six defending
with your queen is not gonna main either
oh my word oh I was about 45 the
software won't let me take a phone call
we have a very special caller welcome to
the show that's know your name and your
question okay this is the bets and Yuri
from hilversum and our question is the
shelf have a great birthday we walked
away from a happy birthday
that was a little bit insider joke there
thank you wifey my wife Yvette calling
from Hilversum with the family to wish
me a happy birthday thank you guys sorry
I can't be there with you but we're
having all a lot of fun here in st.
Louis and we've heard so much about your
nephew Yuri and nice Vivian baby yeah
yeah it's kind of nice to have them on
the show but are you gonna bring them to
st. Louis yeah no wait that's that
that's definitely on our agenda might be
here might be coming up for this year
Cinco fill Cup or maybe even next year's
Super Cup but one of the two and it's
always it's great to hear from you but
but it's even better to actually have
her here of course she really is a ray
of sunshine yeah thank you how'd you
how'd you manage that
uh you know sometimes you just get lucky
really really really lucky and that's my
answer and I'm sticking with it you know
we love you a new home quite soon but I
gotta tell you this position looks
awesome this is the kind of chess
position we want to see because it looks
like ding Lorraine is all over this guy
Rick eight was played wait and the
threat is a two is a two now you want to
play this move but a - yeah as your
tactic doesn't work and right takes is
not going to do anything I mean you
could take if you want to but this is
going to be a girl and this is not me at
all because of the pin so d5a - what are
you going to do right if taking doesn't
work this one is a queen coming that's
right if you take then I guess I could
just take with check well you got to go
up the board right and the bishop is
hanging would check but that's going to
be a one mover and we know how these
positions work he who attacks first
usually mates queen and rook it's so you
could take here I could move
and now your rooks hanging and this
check is hanging and and that King is
that I mean that looks busted this looks
this was I mean unless you have
something to deal with what's about to
come at your King right which looks like
a wave of checks then they're gonna just
fly at this King and remember Queen and
rook versus Queen and rook positions or
even Queen major piece endings of all
stripes a dominant feature in that to
use to just evaluated in general is king
safety right now first you have to
calculate and be very specific to see
what's going on but usually a dominant
feature is king safety and in this
position it is very clear the black King
at least with a moment because you can't
get in a free move pawn takes pawn these
were the moment it's black who's more
secure and this white King that's
wondering am I getting made it in four
or five moves by some sequence of these
pieces attacking with his Queens
checking along the dark squares and this
move rook are back yes I would be
thinking about this move but I'd also be
thinking about a move like this one
threatening the rook threatening Queen
g5 mate as well that's going to get your
attention so this is not easy at all and
I think that his position is too porous
this part on g2 wants to be back on the
board and we are here when 85 was played
in the game
d5 it seems has been played and a - well
we're waiting we've been waiting for
some time in this position after d5 I
don't know looks like member zero is
going down oh my there's been four ding
Moran who if you had won yesterday would
have been at +2 oh my if he had found
that move Knight d8
twice twice and let's take a look at how
Shaq well he started well giving Stivers
yeah with a victory then a draw draw
draw draw and a second victory but since
those two victories in the first five
rounds he's basically drawn all the way
to the current
round 12 where he's engaged in a super
double who's super double-edged position
we think he may be losing Wow
how good is that for Fabiano as saying
that Fabiano does not lose this game now
good for a car yeah Caniff car me I can
bad news is to win it right yeah plus 2
with Abby and mommy Gaurav will be
knocked down to - it's a plus-one and
we've been mentioning earlier that Mommy
Dara's tiebreaks are looking pretty hot
so thanks to the Sonnenberg burger and
his undefeated score as well yeah and
some of the players that he's defeated
yeah and he is how I'd be a dead blow
and Ford Engler into then we have to
look at his road ahead because he's in
there with a shout at +1 if everybody's
at +2 his and I think we did beat her
yakin that's why it was so dangerous for
kayaking to be tied with him because I'm
always gonna lose the tie break because
I had a head so if you can eclipse
Margot ro somehow that's amazing but by
the first he has to be Fabi by the way
by the way let's listen yes before we we
don't get too excited
sorry before we get too excited this is
the Berlin candidates this is crazy
what's happening here every round we're
seeing madness and mayhem I don't think
you could predict anything after this
round no matter what happens whatever
wins losses this has been the soap opera
of candidates for a long time everybody
in contentious so many players in
contention now if IB losses and England
wins then suddenly we have Fabi car yeah
Keon Mahmud's year of Griff shook and
ding Lorraine all 5 in the mix and with
two games with two games to go who knows
what's gonna happen so it is it's nuts
right now
what could and chronic is probably
thinking man if I could have just one
win the game two rounds to go so it has
been a crazy candidates well worth our
our tension and the whole world's eyes
on and Wow it is continuing in this
and we do have some news in that
critical game what yeah if you go along
the lines that you guys are analyzing
with the D 5 a to D 5 a - this was yes a
c6 and yes this marvelous idea it's a
girl it's a girl honey equals Queen yes
no after allowing takes on s 7 with the
idea that there's there's no mate right
yeah
right we can't slip over with our rook
cage fight ship takes f7 yeah we're
analyzing Bishop takes f7 and then they
made time control so a bad time for her
mamita have to make time control now
realizing that none of the ideas are
leading to mate because of this nifty
little you know yesterday well and also
the the defensive powers of the Queen
after Queen age for Queen eight six
right boss well just-just-just I was
just trying to see how bad is it I guess
it's really the the reason that you
don't win at once is that I do have a 2
square protected so what is is there a
real kill here I'm missing something
okay you're saying you also have Queen
d8 right so we can't just play like
we're k-6 allowing Queen ba that what
you're saying well I would be happy to
say and if I saw but yeah we actually
have a caller another special caller
welcome to the show let us know your
name and your question oh thank you my
name is Rex and I'm lost in the
hinterland of Central Missouri and my
question is yasser do you feel not just
older but wiser doing well thank you
we're gonna have to put a filter on our
phone calls will just allow anybody to
call in yes I feel older wiser the
jury's out on that one Rex oh well if
you feel wiser not just older I
and again this is the wiser but
fortunately I'm surrounded by all of
these great minds I guess I'll yeah I
guess I all have to say if you're a
little wiser today well thank you rec
Sinquefield of course he's this yes
[Music]
because that moment I'm still trying to
figure out after work age five right
that was my life let's get guests get to
that position right on your board how
does the black Queen because queen of
six losses to Queen takes Queen right
well maybe not Lulu yeah I think because
you say pawn takes rook takes the King
g7 wins a piece back yes wins the piece
back but then there are these days and
you got three extra pawns so for money
so you can't bring your Queen to the you
you could defend your queen Queen c1 but
then I just trade Queens I'm very happy
and that and you're gonna lose that's
right you have to come up with some way
of exploiting a seven check oh that's a
beauty that's a that's a duck the old
double attack hello Thank You Jennifer
that clears a cobweb what I was thinking
I was wrong and play queen bee to check
so work h5 queen bee to check and then
king g3 and then Queen e5 check oh my
word but it doesn't work at all well
right cuz you can just because there's
no pin or anything and there was no and
I've protected and even if you took the
Queen for free rook h5 check would win
the Queen back so nothing right noble
Queen H Queen a7 check is the simple dad
right we're just up a rock in the end of
the day after that six point eight six
Queen eight six yes I just know that
let's go down that route shadow and
because the dad that that's a beauty
because here I very much doubt it oops
there's an eight oops I had
that's that crop up when you got the two
queens yes
well maurice was mentioning king
protection king safety queen takes and
it's just over there's no not know no
one check you have allow the trade of
Queens that's it well checked yeah you
could have removed your king to g8 and
do the same thing and ride okay but it
does mean that ding glare in this is
over is winning at this moment then how
what again oh well now I have to refresh
the board guys just to see you know that
they have seven and Bishop takes f7
check was playing that's all I mean our
dude play Bishop takes f7 checkerboard I
have problems with the dgt board so that
we are okay gonna be able to show that
position the position with ding Lorraine
so the position you actually have is the
correct a Bishop f7 Bishop f7 and and
that's all we have okay what but maybe
go along they do go along those lines
yeah I think my MIDI Rob is coming to
the realization probably he missed that
Queen a7 move Wow and coming to the
realization that this was over Darren
will win which would be huge
absolutely absolutely and we'll send
Chinese fans into celebration that also
American fans cuz that's really a result
that that bees begging for unfortunately
for American fans though Bobby is in
trouble is he really in trouble on his
game and he he allowed he allowed this
member he was but going back and forth
King da Bishop d2 King CA Queen f1 a
nice waiting moving after route d6 a
pounce
takes takes takes takes Queen a fives
check simple double check and winning
the pond rightly and if we go down this
analysis take your pawn right 10 and
suddenly he has take the pawn on h2 that
was not
played Queen takes was not played in the
game
I believe Bishop c6 now let's see why
Queen Bishop c6 looks scary
Bishop to c6 hitting a rook if you take
the rook I wanted to take on e7 and if
you go rook c7 I want to go Queen g8 so
the engine doesn't like your move
because because because maybe Queen c2
Queen takes e2 okay I could let's try
this line again takes takes oh wait now
Queen c2 you don't have a me oh you can
just dance away yeah exactly
we're threatening mate here observe
check and mate so okay nice Wow
so Queen so this position here Queen
takes why can't
there's got to be another move oh wait
wait check check looks challenging
because if you block and suddenly some
kind of end then a check like this one
is a wonderful discovery you're picking
up both routes yeah that chest
that's pretty I mean yeah rook takes
allowing Queen takes King moves check
and mate check King up Jay gotcha
so you so if you take on h2 and this
check you can't play rogue d8 boy and we
have breaking news guys guys use wait no
I think the breaking news is that Mommy
Durov has resigned and digging around
whoa whoa what a man who could have seen
that coming but seriously that game I
mean that was so cool that tactical idea
at the end of Halloween takes
or qui fais Cheyenne come on Jean 4g5
going for it give him credit for having
all that heart but Bend Madeira he just
went to all too much all in in this game
when he traded off a pair of rooks when
the pair of folks came off the board and
then I saw the bow of g4 in the position
I felt like it's not justified the
attack you you're giving too much for
the limited material that you have on
the board and to attack in that bigger
way when the guy has almost no
weaknesses at all that felt more like a
positional grind position than one you
can say oh you're H pawn is sticking on
h6 oh I'm gonna just make you with g5
that g4 g5 seemed like a dubious plan
and England is spanked it especially
after he traded Knights as well
you can't get rid of pieces in the next
pack to break through a guy's position
and with his weak King ding Lorenzo why
he's such a great attacking player he
will be kicking himself he could have
played 98 yesterday but give him credit
for having all the heart to come back
today that's right in shock perhaps he
was in this game thinking seeing the
rise and ahead of him
I'm only got two more whites I need to
win a game most likely to be in the hunt
for that million dollar match absolutely
you know and it's really all or nothing
and he that's why you went all-in today
but no you could have waited for
tomorrow perhaps but how that impacts
our scoreboard
that's right Fabiano Carolina with seven
points can he drawled this game and
maintain or increase his lead to a full
point I had a mommy da Rev and Bing ran
and that just shows what it the great
import of the game between Sergey and
talk about surging Sergei he does stand
better at this moment in our broadcast
and should he win he will be tied at the
at the top with a B at seven with better
tie breaks eternal wig better
nothing will ever be able to change that
because they won't play each other again
and the head head will be in surgery
sorry Atkins favor Wow having drawn Fabi
earlier in the internet you know just I
mean respect
I mean seriously Sergey started this
tournament so badly he
he was in the cellar he had two losses
and what he has done over those last I'm
gonna say what is it seven rounds has
been nothing short of absolutely
fantastic now let's go back to you can't
say fabulous because he's playing fine
let's go back to Maurice and take a
closer inspection of Abbey's position as
he's struggling to stay alive in this
game what do you have for his movies
well actually i
nolle of the game between ding lauren
and my madeira that is completely
shaking up the standings as the chinese
superstar is now only half a point out
of first the move a three we talked
about this earlier the move g5 happened
this King precariously perched on the f2
square with no protection to speak of
while black banking his counter play
with a3 the black king of course
absolutely secure and it was this after
be for this fantastic move rook ain't
getting the rook out of danger
protecting the bishop you just had a
unit of protection securing the Kings
side and in the meantime white with
nothing to speak of as this pawn was
going down the board and the b4 pawn
about to drop he did go for it with b5
but unfortunately this pawn is not
nearly as dangerous as the a pawn and
after takes then he Queen and now takes
with Czech Bishop takes takes on f7
check in King 287 the critical point
being that rook age 5 is simply not
playable at all instead he played Queen
h4 and after Queen 86 rook h5 hoping for
some chances the move you mentioned gen
Queen to a7 simple port and that's it
you're going to drop this and there's
going to be actually the king h7 was
even smarter than King h8 we
instinctively put it on H set on h8
because we like to avoid light squares
light square attack from the bishop but
by being here he made it even clearer
that you make your next move whatever it
is then simply capture capture you don't
even talk about another check on the
next move that would be it so he
resigned after queen a7 check game over
ding Lauren now showing real fortitude
because remember he drew all those games
he could have won yesterday but he's
he's surging we talked about
surging Sergei he's surging as well
start to look dangerous and being only a
half a point out
hey if car yakin wins and that is still
a long way off but if car yakin wins
then he's only going to be a half a
point behind with two games to play we
see his road so far he had a string of
draws all the way you only see that
number one and around 12 with two rounds
to go and I don't think anybody wants to
play this guy I don't think anybody
wants to play it the way he's shown
himself acquitted himself he said I'm
hard to beat and now
have you started slipping at the end
being Lauren as the as the Challenger
yeah Kim in the last round guys whoa man
yeah Kim I have to win that game so
anything like anything can happen the
story of his candidates is yet to be
written
yesterday Maurice you were talking
lamenting the lament of all chess
players I was winning I was winning yeah
I know next I was winning this is a
tournament I was winning if you think
about bingler in in that grip game and
if he had put that finishing touch on a
masterpiece with 98 he could have been
tied for first if you think about it you
got like how many guys could have said
look if if not just for that one result
I'd be dead if if Abby had won the game
against England hmm okay
ding would be up like just Abby would be
leading by a point and you know we'd be
talking and so many of his games he
would have offered a gift to Fabi
if Aronian had simply just taking a draw
I'm not giving Fabi that victory right
mean there's there's a lot of ifs and
you know yeah I was winning if okay and
talk about possibility and also by the
way if Bingley rented one yesterday with
98 yeah Bank rush
mummy-ji everybody said don't bother
this guy okay you're not gonna play for
g4g father una just relax and and chill
a bit more solidly and play the position
around as it stood he might have felt
like giggling Ren was a bit demoralized
and let me go after him you know
let me just be aggressive aggressive
against them and that's what he decided
to do and Engler in Sudan no I'm not the
one yeah today round is good for his
Alexander Grisha because he's sitting on
plus one watching the door of got
knocked down wonderful that's fantastic
for his chances to win this tournament
as well absolutely and we haven't spoken
about his chances because he is up
against lavona a Roman Aronian he does
have white he's in a position four
versus four this really does look draw
because of the reduced material
essentially one weakness in the position
for a little Levon this backward pawn
that can't be enough simply can't be
enough this games heading towards a draw
over to you Maurice one game that does
not look like it's headed towards a draw
you're talking about it is that game
with Caruana
and after rook DD seven Queen takes g5
that is count of two pawns and a monster
bishop on d5 we mentioned that taking on
h2 is too dangerous you try to trade
Queens
none of that King d8 and then g5 putting
the squeeze on this F pawn so he cannot
move and Queen to d6 again Queen h8 rook
e8 and Queen h4 and guys after Queen g6
the big worry is Harry H pawn move the
Queen out of the way start pushing the
pawn down the board your king is forever
in danger we talk about major piece
endings King safety is an issue well
King say it is an issue pretty much in
any position but particularly in major
piece endings we have here a bishop
that's acting like more than a rook in
fact we see here that this White King
super secure nation right this black
King no home ever in history of time
he's not going to get safe and now this
Queen is going to move out of the way
push the H pawn create this as play and
also look let me look at some kind of
penetration possibilities
this one looks lost this one looks
really really bad again we talked about
two result game I think we're pretty
secure on the fact that this is a two
result game as far as yak is concerned
and he's thinking more like oh it's a
one result game I'm gonna take you down
and this is gonna really change the
standings a very bad game for Fabiano
but give
car yakking credit he sacrificing
exchange Wendy five and said let's make
it happen and it's working in his favor
it really does look grim Wow
great result for the tournament themes
exciting is impossible in the last two
rounds but terrible for the American
fans so absolutely of course as a
commentator I am excited that the last
couple of rounds will be thrilling but
as a Fabi fan this result of being a
loss would be very sad very very sad
indeed
I have some moves I think you just left
us
Maurice after Queen g6 they're getting
close to time control queen g4 sets up a
nasty there is as you're saying the
h-bomb coming there is the potential
even of a discovered attack with Bishop
b4 attacking both Queen and rook on d7
we did have this move rook g5 and just
as you said two pawns
what do you do with pawns you push them
H to H for you should point out that
Queen d7 doesn't work here yes the
immediate Queen I was thinking more
along the lines of Bishop e4 but you're
absolutely right the immediate if you
try to reduce to win an exchange this
move Queen d6 blocks that effort and by
the way for now Bishop f7 as well on me
we take oh sorry you mean oh I
understand excuse me Queen takes King
takes bishop takes f7 discover check but
there's Queen b6
more powerful right and then I'm just
inclined to play pick off this bond
before it becomes a monster as well and
that's why this move H to H for keeping
all of those tactics alive well and
maintaining maybe just maintaining this
pawn on g5 but you know I like your idea
Marie so just you know now the Queen's
on g6 okay your stock over there maybe
it's time for a black partner
White's Queen to start you know start
going take a lot of tickling in this
game and it's not going to be pleasant
like pin pricks yeah particularly you
know and they have the long fingernails
yeah could you cut your nails please
yeah this looks like okay if Abby's
gonna need help to say no saving this
position particularly unfortunate that
we're not it move for Tia and those are
a heck of a three moves to have to make
in high pressure right like you really
want to be able to sink in and defend
right yeah but you also have you need
something to look forward to - right you
say okay one of my fortresses what
pieces do I need to trade off
Blackwood will probably like to just
have the Queen's off the board that
would make his King safety issue less
but it's like you can't achieve any of
those things and you know again just to
you know really buttress the point any
counter-attacks because you're always
looking for calories like like hey I'm
suffering I want to I want to put some I
want to give my opponent problems I and
I'm looking for town turret AK with that
King such a safe cocoon on a - this is
really really really hot terrible it
looks terrible man the energy in the
room judges look well he looked like he
was in trouble for a long time when I
said that - result position you don't
want to be in a tool result position you
don't want to be shifting your King back
and forth King be a king c8 and daring
the guy to find something because
mistakes abound in that situation when
the pressures on and bills and car yakun
need we say what kind of closer this
young man is Wow three out of five
already he's gonna make it four out of
six [ __ ] wins I'm talking about if he
wins this game he would have scored five
points out of the last six games amazing
five points against this crowd what a
and by the way loser in round one draw
two games loser in round four then he
drew two more games we weren't even
talking about him he was in the cellar -
- but then round seven I hit then around
eight a draw another hit in round nine
another draw another hit in round 11 it
looks like another one in round 12 and
no one wants to play him for sure
because Sergey is showing why it is that
he in the big moments can rise he may
not have backed up his win in Moscow by
defeating Magnus Carlsen or by winning
too many tournaments but when it's back
to the candidates when it counts he is
showing that he has the intestinal
fortitude and he's the only one in this
tournament who's ever won a candidate's
and you can see why right now yeah man
I'm just kind of I felt they I thought
the air sucked out of my lungs as well
there because this a result especially
out of the opening I thought that you
know fabbi
had basically way back earlier earlier
earlier let me just go to a physician I
thought that well more or less just
about these parts right here that things
were looking just pretty safe and after
it moved like Bishop f3 I kind of
thought that fabbi was gonna play Queen
c7 double his rooks maybe bring his rook
to e8 maybe just an error of judgment I
still think that you know this Bishop on
d5 an extra pawn big compensation for
white I'm not arguing that point but I
really didn't expect this thing to go
south
maybe exactly at this moment by the way
I coming on the show actually we had
this position I was talking with
Christian about it I didn't expect a
Christian Sharia Grandmaster korilla I
didn't expect the move b7 b6 the problem
I have with that move is it really does
open up this diagonal it always makes it
very unpleasant for black of a White
Queen never lands on the a it's where I
had thought that he was going to play
move like for example King be a queen f2
Bishop f8
and maintain his pawn on on b7 as it
turned out the practical problems that
black was facing God brought him to this
situation where now it's two ponds and I
don't know if we have more moves in the
last move we looked at it was a yeah
your father played key seven and you
know there's all those tactics with
Queen takes d7 but the Queen b3 at the
end your cardiac and played a very quiet
move you play the move rook to d2
quickly also which it can't be fun in
time pressure your opponent just like
slams down Ricky - oh it's like not
exactly the first candidate yeah I mean
he's got ideas rook F - G - he can play
rook g2 and h5 it's curtains also and
he's the discovery oh thank you there
yes and what happened there's a what b5
by Bobby I don't know where that came
from
that's explosive take one f7 disco
happen resigns right well you did not
resign actually you found the move Queen
to f5 only move I'm assuming Queen I
five now that's how many pawns three
pawns that's three went to collect we
could two connected babies on the right
side yes
you got no counter play looks like you
got a trade off rooks yes work takes t7
King take 57 and this took us to move 40
and here we are
we passed well the most direct is just
to take take and g6 oh he asked King e7
I got a veggie party games not just
totally over right there's 97 so that if
g7 you can just take the bishop off with
the king very importantly right okay so
maybe you don't want to push that one so
fast then
well how's this Jen I mean I'm getting a
four to two majority on the other side
as well
thank you can I round up the aged pawn
though with work age five considering
that G sevens always met by King takes
off seven correct that's a nice pawn to
get right so wait I mean what you should
be winning right but is it that easy
he still hasn't work to do what if he
doesn't trade Queen exactly so let's
just see what we do have we have Bishop
takes f7 Queen of five rook takes King
takes and Maurice is just asked a very
salient question how do we avoid trade
in Queens Maurice we drop back drop we
check yeah we drop back with a check
seven most likely King he's seven and
moved my bishop maybe push push push I
want you thinking about this pawn
forever I want you to never stop
thinking about this pawn okay well we
always have resins so let's just I don't
know take a pawn all right now the Queen
has to sneak in wow-whee not Queen d2
Queen d2 Queen d2 we need to and and
what I'm trying to sneak in is over that
way it's over there or maybe over there
although Sergey did choose to go for the
endgame thought it was winning so we are
gonna be great right and you know check
back in on this critical game and see if
a new sir can make a girl and and burst
the tournament wide open
oh definitely Wow we'll be back in just
a few minutes
[Music]
as the st. Louis chess club celebrates
its 10th anniversary the US
Championships returned to st. Louis for
the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and sabina
Poyser will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club org
health care in America is changing
evolving and we're helping lead the
transformation ascension is made up of
physicians and other caregivers called
to deliver compassionate personalized
care for all as one of the largest
providers of care in the country our
patients benefit from collaboration
between hospitals medical practices and
healthcare innovators nationwide
ascensions faith-based heritage means we
have a moral obligation to serve
everyone especially those who are
struggling last year we provided almost
two billion dollars in care for people
living in poverty and for programs to
help them whether it's in a hospital a
neighborhood clinic a senior living
facility or at home ascensions care
providers value every aspect of our
patients lives and health we listen with
respect to ensure every person we serve
gets the right care for them
personalized compassionate that's
Ascension
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today in chess
we're today in st. Louis there is a
sadness in the air is it looks like
Fabiano Khurana could be going down to
surgery cracking but let's not kind of
out just yet are there some defensive
possibilities in the same game Yasir
well let's take a look with that they
did the players did follow the line that
we were analyzing we'll just take it
from this moment they did Sergey did go
for the Queen trade Maurice was
mentioning it was also possible for
white to continue playing with the
Queen's on the board after the move g7 g
6g v g6 pardon me you're threatening g7
and the Queen King e7 was forced Sergey
clipped that pawn on b5 rook h4 and
after this move c4 rook takes h4 he's
just played this move
a4 and I thought there might be
possibilities of defense but I'm
anticipating that white will just play
the move a5 the king will have to go to
d6 and at a certain moment white is this
going to bring his king up the board
play this move b4 and I don't see the
defensive possibilities this 4 vs. 2
majority is just too much it's too easy
a right like White's not exactly a
rocket scientist in this position would
clean it up that would absolutely no
question about it because okay you can
you you you're just waiting and that's
basically all you can do is wait maybe
there is some some trick where the 1800
would fall to a Bobby I know Carolina
like you know maybe there's something
but you know Sergey Kuryakin it it does
seem a little too easy doesn't it yes it
does it does
b6 is on tap and Wow
Maurice what do you got for us
it's a tough situation for Fabi and what
can we say the tournament is gonna be
blow wide open let's take a look at the
standings the updated stands I'd love to
see that list because now we can start
making some projections as it's it's
mayhem madness and mayhem all right we
have a position pending with Fabi and
ding Lou and Sergei Kuryakin we suspect
that teriyaki is gonna win that game my
Maddy robbed at 6 and a half
ding Lorraine at six and a half and
Richard trying to make something happen
in that game against Aronian but it
should also bring him to six and a half
crime that get five and a half we'll be
outside for sure of being able to come
back it'd be incredible somehow he could
make it to ties in some math but with
that jumbo at the top no predictions can
be made and none all we know is ding
Loren started to play well and we do
have breaking news in fact it seems as
though it has happened yes we expected
it
Sergei Kuryakin scoring four wins out of
six games has defeated Fabiano Caruana
repeating the result from two years ago
when he defeated Caruana then in Moscow
in the last round and went on to become
the Challenger to magnus carlsen he has
done this now in a different way
bringing a win to bring himself into a
tie with Caruana
but there are two runs to go so fab fab
e's fans there feeling like he still has
a chance with two runs ago and he
absolutely does anything could happen in
this story further the parallel between
two years ago and that's when a man
Sergei car yakun and Fabiano Khurana
plead in the last row they had the same
number of points one would think a draw
would be okay they tie for first right
but just like in this case it's not
going to be enough it's all about the
type rates
Bobby had worst high breaks in crack in
that year and this year any time they
had the same number of points the first
tie break is head to head savvy is going
to lose this so he has lost because he
lost a he lost to Sergei karyakin he's
always gonna lose on tiebreaks at suriak
Ariake
if there's a tie for
earth so actually this loss is even
worse than it looks
for darken fan exactly means Bobby has
got to get one and a half out of two in
the next two rounds and yes only get one
out of two obviously Sergei losing one
of his games yeah and he does play
zingaran
in the last round who will be super
motivated absolutely so still anything
can happen but a really terrible outcome
no doubt for Fabiano Caruana will have
to do more investigations but you're
talking about tiebreaks imagining that
that sergei finishes his a wonderful
assuming burn down the building
Wow nobody touch the pecan pie
yeah only made the wish that you just
made yesterday yeah not a wooden of laws
no way I wasn't 26 there I think I'm 60
seriously 26 now nice friend Anton
squared he always has the best photo
shops
from people big fans including a little
problem from the hashtag night of good
who says from Damascus to Seattle he is
always ready to battle Yasser is our
hero first-place never zero path pawns
push a baby
Andrew Barrett Chris and David now
Edward Frank George and Hank Gardner 64
square lon
because Yasser will grab your call very
creative passed pawns today it's like
not really what we want to hear about
yeah yeah they were the downfall of our
own Fabiano carolina no kidding
Sergei just pushed his pawns and I said
I suspect at the end he recognized that
in fact whites King doesn't have to just
play with his majority but he can go
over and support his past g7 pawn
because now blacks King is forever
trapped on the Queen side so the past
pawns
by the way well we got a bad news in
relief for the largely American audience
of today in class I'm sure some we have
to have some Sergei fans but we got that
bad news we also have more news Grisha a
game between Levon Aronian
as expected was it draw but you know
what today was actually an awesome pay
for Grisha and you know you should be
looking around and saying like the
tournament have gone way up if I hurt
you of what happened in the games with
Kuryakin and especially Mahmud are
losing this all-important 12th round
there's our results beyond Oh
whereas before he was a full point ahead
of the leaders now it may not matter
much as much as you think because he's
so probably gonna have a task in the
final round to be Fabio with life yeah
we won't have our resources or yeah
we'll have our resources trying to
figure out these tiebreaks but
when we were saying is a two horse race
it's a second okay if you take a look at
this list the rib according to the
tiebreak circuit kuryakin's tiebreak is
better than fabi's right now because he
defeated Fabi in head-to-head right so
that's one and I'm also yeah more wins
he has now five wins in this competition
five wins more than anyone else sorry it
must be before wins four wins but still
more than anyone else right in the
competition and his before yeah
so he has more wins than Fabi and so
that tie break he's better on the second
tie break and a head-to-head so better
in the first tiebreaker
so that puts him really in first place
his name should be above Bobby's right
now technically Diggler in his name
should be over in my maduro's because
this tie break is better than my girls
cuz he hit let me tear up there and say
hey means anything month so my Madeira
effectively Xin is in fourth place right
right now correct and Gris Chuck
although mommy did be crackin so that
helps it they both time they both talk
yeah they're the only two who tie so
there's a lot of little head-to-head
infighting going on amongst the top now
did Richard beat any of these players I
don't know we'll double check on that
but this is the playoff format or rather
the tiebreak format again the number one
tie break a is the players involved in
the tie and the games that they've
played between themselves
should that be even or equal then they
go to puck tie break B which is what
you've just been describing for wins for
Sergei sir ascertain if Sergei gets in a
tie he's looking gold and if that should
be drawn at tied then it's the
Sonnenberg burger and because of the
these two results Sergei winning today
that is a great improves his son of
their burger as doesn't ding Blair in
because Shaq was number two coming into
this round although it doesn't look like
it's gonna get to that time right
somehow it seems that that one of the
other two will pretty much decided I
think in most incarnations but Wow well
too
we're Kramnik and beat so so he is not
you he won you want again so in Kramnik
oh I see right so he's so his time rates
are not great no in fact he only has he
only has two wins even if he gets three
wins his tiebreaks will not be great
plus two will not do it for him although
if he beats Bobby in the last round yeah
I guess that doesn't even really matter
because who actually now leapfrog over
Bobby
and that's Bobby wins a lot of math
story but this is Bobby's road this far
well hey he's got a rest day and you
know because of what we've been saying
about mommy Darrow's tiebreaks I mean
sorry about a cracking cyber egg feeling
better than his mommy daughters would
have been as well um Bobby probably has
to go in tomorrow versal Vaughn aronia
and he has to win yeah either that or in
last round those are the life visas
there's black choices again sweetheart
depends on tomorrow's result yeah I mean
next games results in two days because
we have my other day off just a reminder
on to two points Morrow Sunday is a free
day for the players and ourselves but on
Monday we'll be starting an hour earlier
because of daylight savings important
reminder indeed in the United States we
have daylight savings earlier than they
have it in Europe so we're gonna be
starting at 11:00 central as opposed to
comes these are our Monday pairings if
we thought today's pairings were vital
to the tournament take a look at what we
have in store on Monday every game
matters every game matters it certainly
does and American fans Wesley you
haven't had a good tournament but you
Wesley where I go as way I'll bring my
pom-poms and fabbi versus LaVon a and
Dean also in the hunt mammy
every game that that game at the top
definitely every juror was only tied
with Richard and he realizes the last
white that he's gonna have how is he
gonna handle what he did today by the
way he could have just played
conservatively today not of course he
would g45 he'd be in first she'd be type
of person with no problem right I don't
know why he went all in so desperately
it just looked dubious what he was doing
he didn't handle himself the right way
yeah sir I think you made this big point
in that game where he could have played
ninety three instead of allowing a trade
of knights what's the position pieces
left the board then was all about King
position and now we have this score
ahead of us why don't we have Bobby's
rating here by the way I'm just trying
to figure out the only one who doesn't
have a rating reading broken all the
calculator yeah right I don't think so
but you know Maurice listening to you
when you were describing sir gaze
extraordinary run I mean five out of six
if you were just to isolate those
results five out of six he's playing at
three thousand god I mean there's
amazing the guy was on the bottom of the
tournament he's in the cellar you know
question a seller and look at his name
right now I mean absolutely incredible
like you said four wins out of six games
that totals and two draws that with two
draws that told those five points out of
six see my belief about this event is
you want to say to everybody else I am
the man I am the rightful challenger and
the rest of you are just pretenders
that's what you want to say when you
play this kind of tournament you go back
to somebody like Bobby Fischer for
example when he stormed through the
opposition okay nobody's gonna do that
again because he just ripped everybody
in front of him in his matches against
Larsen and match against time I know of
match against Petrosian and he said you
guys please I'm the man now Spassky it's
your turn to take this boot you want to
have that kind of performance and Sergei
started off slow and now he's saying no
excuse me you guys don't have the heart
like I have it I'm the one you're
supposed to be worried about and you
should have been worried about and you
saw me dropped a couple of games but
here he's coming back like a true
challenger and boy I think if he stays
stable at which it looks like he can he
just seems to do
he's just the odds-on favorite to win
this event again absolutely basically
he's got split odds he's got tie
breakouts right just buttressing exactly
what you're saying about throttling the
field and saying I'm number one I'm the
guy who's winning it I mean I'm
forcefully reminded of extraordinary
performance of Veselin Topalov in Sam
Louise that was for the world
championship he he just blew the
competition out of the water with the
plus six then I'm thinking about Vishy
Anand at Mexico City same situation it
was for the World Championship he took
that tournament by storm and never never
relinquished it and so what Sergei is
doing now is just mind-boggling it's
fantastic but who's got the better road
ahead
so with black and England with white is
is Sergei zorder and say say it again so
Wesley
of course right and then he please ding
maroon with white in the minor Wow that
sounds like he's got his destiny in his
own hands but go on yes white would live
on black with grey sure yeah so I mean
he also in a way has the destiny on his
side because he knows that Greece is
gonna be trying to play for a win so
he'll probably have a shot in that game
yeah and lavon's the one with the target
on his back
even though LaVon played a good game
today and held Richard at bay it's
really a toss-up there because ding
quran' is finding his fire Grisha been
you know playing playing pretty well
during the day and then then you've got
so in the bottom who are both having bad
tournaments but Aronian of course on an
even bigger downswing and
last few hours remind me again about
Mami's road ahead who's got two gigs
well I mean ours I was a interesting one
as well he's got white tomorrow might on
Monday sorry with white tomorrow and
then he plays kramnik with black in the
final round
so Kramnik with black so that's good
looking crime they keep got a spoiler
spoiler I don't she has a spoiler he's
gonna be in there trying to stabilize
but dig but crumbling oh he's going in
swinging no matter what it as he's
played he could be the one people saying
good I'm glad you're playing chronic it
was anything could happen but then again
you know kramnik could also just lose
those games
given that the way he's he's been
playing so it's rosie who who will be
the one that taste ground mix genius or
maybe his overestimation he have a
position that causes them to lose but
for Dana Brennan and I think that's
actually good because they are a point
behind so they want there to be a
greater chance of a decisive role you're
either you're either in or you're out
that's what they want wow that the table
is being set for an absolutely
absolutely dramatic finish to this
extraordinary candidates tournament
Maurice we're gonna turn it over to you
to share your final thoughts because
what attorney what could you say indeed
what can be said it's just been fighting
chess from round one I mean we could
they didn't come in trying to warm up to
this tournament it was immediately the
gloves were off and it was just simply
MMA in here they just wanted to beat
everybody up and let's go and we have
seen it we've seen that fighting spirit
has been a tremendous event they putting
it all on the line that today was
definitely a sad day for the leader
Fabiano Caruana and for Americans but it
has indeed turned into a free-for-all
once again a crazy tournament nobody can
make any predictions about what's going
to happen except some more crazy stuff
is going to go on so exciting toward an
arrest day I had as well to give all the
players fighting energy it should be
amazing on Monday yeah yes that boy I do
feel so deflated at this exact moment in
time I hope it won't be a funeral wake
on
I'm still optimistic yeah like I like
that rest day I like the Bobby's gonna
be able to get a chance let's put it
this way
he might not qualify but he's gonna get
his chances and that extra rounds he's
gonna be in there he's playing against
guys who have a lot of stake as well and
he you know if he brings it he has a
very good chance of becoming the
Challenger to Magnus
so I want to show you just taken aback
this was not the birthday present I said
he's gonna happen but he's gonna have
his chances so I like that it could it
could be I mean you know he could be
playing against you know perhaps like
sowing aronia in the last two great
games people who might not be is insane
tries to blow it open so I do like those
pairings I hate to mention it but let's
point out that a permanent wins all of
his last three games he could be a
contender do are you serious you would
bring him to the +2 nobody is plus 3 yet
so plus 2 would give you a chance but he
has to win three in a row Wow Wow
well first he would have to win this
game does he have winning chances the
position I have it really looks like it
like Wesley's gonna sit hold on oh yeah
well folks it's been as a as always an
eventful day here in today in chess and
we're gonna see you Monday for another
extraordinary edition of the show happy
birthday as I know it wasn't the gift
that you had in mind to me it will give
you some belated birthday gifts we will
find out on Monday I'm Jennifer shotty
with Yasir saralyn and Maurice Ashley
from the st. Louis chess club and we
will see you in a couple days
[Music]